star wars battlefront was fairly well  received but one of the most common  complaints was the lack of a single  player campaign this mode has been  teased for the sequel before but now  it's all but confirmed ea's Justin  McCully appeared on the achievement  oriented podcast where he commented on  the team's plans for battlefront 2 he  stated the focus of the first game was  to nail the core multiplayer experience  of what dice does great we heard the  fans loud and clear that the multiplayer  was great but it wasn't enough than they  wanted that complete package so the team  has been very focused on delivering that  single-player element McCully also  mentioned that star wars battlefront 2  is currently slated for holiday 2017  more recently the first games rogue 1  dlc and x-wing VR mission are available  now we'll definitely be hearing more  about the sequel next year and to keep  up with all of it you're already in the  right place  you